so of course we are all now talking
about the fact that she has revealed
that
she had a miscarriage in july but this
article that she's written for the new
york times is part of a wider message
that she's trying to get across saying
that
actually 2020 has been a really
difficult year for everybody
and it's a time where we should ask are
you okay but she's obviously been very
keen to use
her own personal experience it is quite
a heartbreaking
article that she's written i think if
anyone had written it we would
uh say how brave they were but of course
duchess of sussex
is one of the most famous women in the
world and knows that everything that she
says is going to be
picked apart in the article she says i
knew as i clutched my firstborn child
that i was losing my second
hours later i lay in a hospital bed
holding my husband's hand
i felt the clamminess of his palm and
kissed his knuckles
wet from both our tears staring at the
cold white walls my eyes glazed over
i tried to imagine how we'd feel
now i'm told that even from that moment
they were very keen that this was an
experience that they would be
able to publicly talk about they've
decided that
now is the right moment the article
i think is written in words that are
incredibly raw
give us this insight that many would not
expect from a member of the royal family
it is worth saying though that zara
tindall so princess anne's
daughter has previously also spoken
about having uh two miscarriages but
also i think you need to put this in the
context that harry and megan have been
criticized recently about oversharing
about the issues that they've talked
about
but i think that this article shows that
megan has this deep conviction
that yes she is going to have these
conversations she is going to get people
talking about these issues
no matter what her critics are going to
say about her